angela merkel so war diese woche zu
hören erhofft sich einen neuen push in
der zusammenarbeit mit frankreich
konkreter ist wieder leider nicht
geworden
wichtig ist nur dass es nichts kostet
claus von wagner leitet das goethe
institut in paris ja von wagner
was ändert sich denn jetzt in den
deutsch-französischen beziehungen da
muss ich sie jetzt leider gleich mal
korrigieren wir heißen gar nicht mehr
goethe institut
wir sind auch sofort dass schäuble
institut den basti franzosen dringend
von uns lernen müssen
das ist ja nicht das ist ja nicht der
schüler das sind die grundrechenarten -
plus von geteilt will ich gar nicht
reden dass kinder franzose und hügel so
will ich gehen dass du wirklich dass
wirklich alles erklären
der durchschnittslohn claire von neben
haben der weiß nicht was sparen
überhaupt nicht gespart für mich eine
mutter vereint schwedische auswahl
eigentlich nur wenn man wenn man geld
ausgibt das man hat wenn man weniger
geld ausgibt als man nicht hat aber
immer noch mehr als man halt
[Applaus]
start ist es immer weniger geld ausgeben
als man mehr nicht hat kommt er
plötzlich also die franzosen sollen in
erster linie von uns deutschen lernen
vom wem denn sonst vom spanier
vielleicht einfach mal nur eine stunde
mittagspause vielleicht nicht immer
schon am vormittag die erste flasche
rotwein köpfen
er muss sich so viel ändern ich sage
mindestlohn 9 eur 76 9 eur 76 18 euro
sie sind die sondern auch dumpinglöhne
zahlen als sie mit deutschen sind ja
nicht exportweltmeister wir den ganzen
tag besoffen am kollegen schnecken
fressen und unserem budget kann sie 20
prozent der angestellten in deutschland
arbeiten für unter zehn euro
das ist vorbildlich das darf ich dann ja
auch wohl vom feinen herren franzosen
auch mal erwartet was haben wir da eine
ganze woche einfach mal scheiterten
kaufen
das schmeckt genauso gut nein so dass
nicht ja herr von wagen also richtig
beliebt machen uns so aber auch nicht
beliebt hat keine miete leiharbeitern
muss man hier den gleichen lohn zahlen
plus zehn prozent aufschlag
die wahnsinnigen franzosen haben einen
regelrechten kündigungsschutz
kündigungsschutz machen müssen was darf
man gar nicht einfach so jemanden
rausschmeißen
immerhin wo soll das enden urlaub kann
man diskutieren wie die rente mit 62 in
frankreich aber wir sollten uns jetzt
trotzdem nicht verhalten wie oberlehrer
oder kolonialherren entschuldigen da
haben sie natürlich recht
aber ich sag mal so wenn mir was
auffällt als nachbar
als freund wo die franz akten einfach
schlimme fehler machen dann helfe ich
doch hier zum beispiel musste in der
euroblech turm wirklich die ganze nacht
beleuchtet werden von meinem geld ich
meine nein
[Musik]
[Applaus]